As you saw earlier in the course,
protocol stacks are made of layers.
For each layer depends on abstractions
provided by the layer below.
Let's take another look up and
down that stack to see where we are.
As a developer,
you're usually working at one particular
layer of abstraction at a time.
But it's important to know
about the lower layers,
because the way they work affects
the way they can fail, and
what strange things can
happen to your application.
Web applications rely on HTTP to
send requests about resources and
get responses.
You use libraries like Flask or
requests to build HTTP applications.
Some ideas that are visible at
the HTTP layer include URLs for
resources and methods,
cookies, HTTP verbs.
Any misbehavior of lower layers is
mostly visible at the HTTP layer
as errors and high latency.
Requests that fail, or
the take unreasonably long to complete.
HTTP is implemented in browsers and
in web servers,
as well as in proxies and firewalls,
and some other tools like that.
That code uses TCP.
But the code that says in order to send
an HTTP request, connect to the server
on port 80 and transmit the following
bytes is part of the web browser.
And the corresponding code for
understanding HTTP requests and
sending responses is
part of the web server.
Web apps don't need to reinvent that.
They just make use of the features the
browser and server already implement.
But the browser up here
doesn't tell your Wi-Fi or
ethernet adapter down here exactly
what to transmit to your router.
The browser makes use of the TCP
networking services that your
operating system provides.
Connecting to a server on a port and
having a reliable stream of
bytes between that client and
server is a feature provided by
your OS's TCP implementation.
Whether you're on Mac or Windows or
Linux or something else.
Modern OSs provide TCP built in.
User program such as browsers
just have to use them.
Within the OSs networking
code TCP in turn
relies on the lower level protocol
IP to deliver packets between hosts.
And to pass them through
the intermediate hops, the routers.
An IP in turn, relies on hardware like
Wi-Fi or ethernet and device drivers to
physically shift data between devices
on the same physical network.
Now, not all network
applications use TCP.
Ping uses ICMP.
DNS primarily uses UDP as to a number
of other things like the network time
protocol that keeps your time and
date in sync.
But all of these underlying protocols
are provided by the operating system.
We'll see a lot more about
these in this lesson.
One more thing, be careful what
layer you're talking about.
There are a lot of terms
in common between them.
For example, a Wi-Fi connection or
associating with a particular Wi-Fi
access point has nothing particularly
to do with a TCP connection,
also known as a session.
And a TCP session has nothing
particularly to do with a web user
session, identified by, for instance,
session cookies on a logged in user.